[Music]
good evening and happy independence day
i'm trey gowdy and welcome to sunday
night in america thank you for joining
us
on july 4 1776 the most
consequential country in history
announced itself to the world
and for nearly 250 years the united
states of america
has been a source of light a source of
justice
a source of prosperity and a sanctuary
for those fleeing oppression
our sons and daughters have died on
foreign battlefields
defending and liberating others we're
the first to help when others are in
need
even those who don't always remember
and it all started with an idea it
started with an
aspiration even as we celebrate america
today
it is appropriate to look back on
america
on its first day the most significant
line in america's birth certificate
is this we hold these truths to be
self-evident
that all men are created equal that they
are endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights
that among these are life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness we hold
these truths to be self-evident
there it is the word truth the
acknowledgement that there is something
called truth
and it need not be hidden from mankind
it is
self-evident which means these truths do
not
derive from others we're not granted to
us
as favor and we're not waiting for
others to illuminate those
truths for us they are indeed
self-evident and then the most
fundamental concept of all
that all men are created equal
what a worthy aspiration the intrinsic
equality of mankind
and then the source of these truths is
acknowledged
endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights
we hear the word rights often in our
culture but how often do we reflect on
what the word means
and the source of those rights
it is clear those who dreamed and
breathed life into this idea of america
believed you were born with certain
rights and those rights did not come
from government
or the consent of your fellow citizens
these rights were not
given to you these rights are part of
you
and they cannot be stripped away and
then a phrase occasionally overlooked
the phrase among these are
this lets us know what follows is not
the complete list of your rights or else
they would not have taken care to remind
us that
among these rights are life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
it is widely believed thomas jefferson
was the primary author of our
declaration of independence
one of the founding fathers i enjoy
reading was his great friend james
madison
and it was madison who put a touch of
realism and practicality into this
aspiration known as america it was
madison who said if men were angels
no government would be necessary
july 4th is the ideal time to note the
difference between what we
aspired to be and the realities
of where we are the declaration of
independence was the
ideal the constitution was an effort to
turn the ideal
into a government and i do reflect on
what could have been had we taken the
majesty of that clause
all men are created equal
and fully turned it into our governing
document
but even in that governing document
america acknowledged two things
number one we are in a perpetual
search for a more perfect union
and number two while truth does not
change
our constitution could and should
and would be amended to better reflect
that truth america set for itself
the highest ideal the highest goal
the highest aspiration and when you set
truth as your ideal
and seek a perfect union
you will often times find both out of
reach but that is the beauty and
uniqueness of america
we set a goal that is so hard to reach
because
truth is the only goal worth
setting and i would rather be a country
that strove for the impossible
than a country that's settled for what
is easy
there is nothing easy about democracy
it is hard it can be messy
we are not a perfect country because
there is no such
thing but we are a good people
constantly striving to be a perfect
union of people
so happy birthday america you have gone
from a band of revolutionaries who
believed in self-rule
to the greatest experiment and
self-governance the world
has ever known
and while it is your birthday it is you
america
who has given the gift the gift of
showing what is
possible when you believe in truth
when you believe in life when you
believe in liberty
and are constantly searching
for that more perfect union
our next hour will serve as a salute to
service
and a celebration of our great nation
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else